bonjour
lourd et riche aujourd'hui montpellier
pour la réunion des ministres
européens du développement
était à remercier
la france et au ministre jean-yves
d'audience mon ami d'adrien pour son
hospitalité
la réunion a été dominée par l'invasion
de l'ukraine à la russie
qui pose un énorme problème
humanitaire
l'armée russe
poursuit son offensive
en ukraine le nombre des civils tués on
monte le jour le jour et on est dans un
processus de destruction systématique
des infrastructures
pas seulement militaire mais sybille
c'est des habitations sais
c'est une facture civils qui sont prises
possible d'une façon systématique
évidemment ça n'a fait qu'augmenter
le nombre de réfugiés qui franchissent
les frontières de l'europe
déjà on a dépassé le chiffre de 1
million et demi c'est plutôt un million
six cent mille vous voyez quelle vitesse
ça on monte et on craint fort que la fif
c'est une estimation raisonnable
ça peut arriver à 5 millions de
personnes
on a vu
depuis la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
un mouvement de réfugiés
aussi grand on s'est produit 100 aussi
vite
cette énorme quantité des gens qui
quitte son pays pour échapper à la
guerre
devront être accueillis par les pays
européens
il y à des estimations qui disent que
plus de 18 millions de personnes seront
touchées par les conflits à l'intérieur
de l'ukraine
on a discuté la réponse à cette
situation
nous avons identifié un premier
versement de presque 100 millions
d'euros pour une aide humanitaire
immédiate
à nos partenaires
en ukraine et en moldavie
c'est finalement
fédéral à fournir à nous redire en lots
santé des abris la protection des vases
pour ses citoyens ukrainiens
dans ce contexte nous allons remonter la
résilience de l'ukraine et de la
moldavie
la moldavie en particulier un pays qui
se sent menacé et qui a besoin d'une
aide à la fois économiques et politiques
on va travailler aussi rapidement pour
la mobilisation de un paquet de 500
millions d'euros pour l'ukraine qui a
été annoncé par la présidente de la
commission européenne pour aider les
populations touchées par le conflit
il faudra continuer à aider l'ukraine
dans les domaines de la sécurité de la
saveur security
mais l'important ce moment c
et d de flux' de réfugiés
j'ai continué à travailler pour essayer
de trouver
ces failles au le feu qu'ils puissent
commencer à ouvrir la porte à une
négociation
l'autre côté la réunion ils étaient
présentes la banque européenne
d'investissement
qui a décidé de réorienter
600 700 millions d'euros pour soutenir
la liquidité et l'économie ukrainienne
ça en ce qui fait référence au conflit
ukrainien
nous avons aussi avorté à une question
de caractère structurel c'est la
dimension géopolitique de l'europe
nous avons besoin de blanc demande d'une
façon ou d'une europe plusieurs
politiques y compris dans la façon de
concevoir
je vais faire de la coopération et du
développement
il nous faut clarté d'une opportunité
il nous faut faire mais t es une nouveau
crédibilité
il faut sortir de la logique des
annonces rhétorique est passé et des
offres concrètes et réalistes que nos
partenaires puissent prendre sur yeux et
qui soit susceptible de faire la
différence
oui nous voulons tous une rupture
politique
mais comment tout d'abord il faut être
plus affirmatif plus de terminer dans la
défense de nos valeurs et de nos
intérêts et l'accusant crânienne
agi comme un catalyseur
dans la recherche de cette europe
plusieurs politiques utilisent tous ses
moyens pour influencer sur le destin du
monde
pour influencer sur nos partenaires de
référence
il pour tenir compte de son pote dans
les nations unies pour savoir à quel
point se sont alignées avec les
positions que nous défendons
il prit finalement on a eu l'occasion
pendant le déjeuner de discuter sur le
problème des caractères global dont on
ne parle pas assez celle du bio
diversité
on parle beaucoup des changements
climatiques on parle beaucoup moins de
la perte de biodiversité
que nous avons eu l'occasion d'en
discuter de l'ancien président du niger
mais s'il échoue il souffre ou est un
ancien étudiant dans l'université de
montpellier sur la manière d'intégrer la
biodiversité dans les politiques
dead au développement ainsi que la
contribution que l'union européenne peut
faire à la recherche agricole en afrique
je compose paraître secondaire
n'ayant comme nous tous avant les yeux
braqués sur ce qui se passe en ukraine
mais elles sont pas secondaire
n'ont pas l'urgence les dramatisme de la
d'ukraine mais la perte de biodiversité
est un problème mondial
transversale qui nous touchent à tous et
qui va nous poser beaucoup de problèmes
à nos court terme
et donc
il faut supposer il faut y travailler
parce que la perte de biodiversité
c'est une grande menace pour le
développement durable
et pour l'objectif final de lutte contre
la pauvreté ça a été une discussion
passionnante mais je comprends fort bien
qu'aujourd'hui l'intérêt sur le club se
pose à tous le conseil a voulu ouvrir un
riche à pitre et sa discussion sur le
sujet merci encore à la france
pour avoir accueilli cette rencontre
merci à montpellier au sens et
spontanéité
oui quelques mots pour compléter ce que
vient de dire le représentant qui a
rendu compte de l'essentiel des travaux
j'aurais d'abord vous dire tout le
plaisir que la france a eu d'organiser
cette réunion informelle ici à
montpellier remercié les autorités
locales monsieur le maire de
l'accompagnement que vous avez bien
voulu mener pour la bonne tenue de cette
réunion informelle merci aussi monsieur
le préfet de services de la préfecture
qui nous ont accompagnés c'était
important
malgré tout de tenir ce sommet ces deux
rencontres informelles quand on dit
rencontres informelles c'est à dire
qu'il a pas de décision prise à la fin
de la réunion et nous tenons à ce que
cette
réunion soit organisée à montpellier
parce que il ya ici d'abord eu un sommet
afrique-france
mémorable à l'automne dernier et puis
qu'il y à aussi ici sur les sujets qui
concernent le développement
une tradition d'innovation de recherche
d'intervention avec le cirad d'une part
cjr d'autre part plus les enjeux
d'agro écologie qui sont développés dans
l'ensemble de ce coût pour eux je
pourrais appeler une espèce de klosters
agroécologiques de de montpellier qui
fait que ça donne de la force et de la
résonance aux sujets que nous avons
abordé aujourd'hui et singulièrement je
lui dis monsieur le maire au troisième
sujet que nous avons abordé avec le
président il souffre aux sur
l'affirmation du grand projet de la
grande muraille verte qui est un projet
agro écologiques qui regroupe onze pays
du sahel qui mobilise aujourd'hui 16
milliards d'euros et qui a pour objectif
de non seulement de créer deux rails
verte son nom est suffisamment évocateur
mais de faire en sorte que de
de la guinée-bissau jusqu'à djibouti
puisse y avoir cette mise en valeur
d'une nouvelle histoire du sel qui
permettrait de fixer des populations qui
permettrait aussi d'assurer une nouvelle
agriculture et qui permettrait aussi
d'assurer la stabilité et que le
président issoufou reviennent pour
parler de cela a été pour nous tous pour
les vingt-sept très mobilisateur très
passionnant dans les perspectives et le
fait que ce que pour ma part je ne
savais pas
mais je pense que personne ne les avait
vraiment que le président issoufou et
fait ses études à montpellier qui
reviennent 46 ans après ici dans une
autre histoire d'une autre aventure
c'était quand même assez émouvant
sur avant de revenir à l'ukraine sur
les enjeux géopolitiques je pense que ce
que je retire je crois que c'est assez
partagé par josep borrell que je sais
que nous pensons vraiment la même chose
sur ce sujet c'est que sur les enjeux
géopolitiques du développement c'est que
l'europe doit tenir sa place
nous nous sommes les premiers bailleurs
au niveau mondial des dettes publiques
au développement les européens tous
réunis team europe et nous ne disons pas
ce bien plus important que la chine
compte comme les états unis dans l'aide
au développement partout dans le monde
et singulièrement en afrique mais pas
uniquement et nous le disons pas parce
qu'une espèce de l'absence de lisibilité
de ce que nous sommes je crois que ce
matin nous avons vraiment cette option
d'affirmer que l'europe et ce partenaire
là et qu'elle doit s'articuler aux
réalités d'une compétition
internationale parce que le
développement c'est aussi une
compétition d' influence on le voit
d'ailleurs dans certains votes aux
nations unies et nous devons nous mêmes
évitez d'instrumentaliser le
développement à des fins politiciennes
les fins de suggestions mais développe
et faire en sorte que le développement
soit un outil de partenariat qui
respecte la souveraineté des pays avec
lesquels nous sommes en co développement
puisqu'il ya des sujets du développement
qui sont obligatoirement partenariat que
ce soit la lutte pour le réchauffement
climatique ou les enjeux de biens
d'exercice et de l'eau rien de parler
donc je ressort de cette réunion avec la
conviction c'est être prise de
conscience de l'affirmation de l'europe
comme
de développement et comme ayant la
capacité d'établir des partenariats qui
évite la suggestion ou la dépendance
alors que certains autres en font leur
priorité et puis nous avons évidemment
parlé l'ukraine longuement
le drame qui se joue cette tragédie
dans
nous sommes loin d'être sortis
avec la mobilisation financière dont tu
as parlé josep borrell à la fois sur
l'aide humanitaire
les 500 millions d'euros qui sont et qui
ont été annoncés la france y contribuera
elle aussi puisque nous avons à la
demande du président de la république
que décidé de mobiliser 100 millions
d'euros d'aidé humanitaire pour les
réfugiés
ou les déplacés et les réfugiés et
déplacés dans sur l'espace ukrainien et
puis nous avons aussi décidé de
l'accompagner les financements
budgétaire
sur la part d un milliard deux que tu as
évoqué tout à l'heure la france
mobilisera 300 millions d'euros mais ça
c'est pour l'immédiateté nous sommes
partis dans un drame de longue durée sur
lequel nous sommes extrêmement mobilisés
parce qu'on voit bien que ce qui est
recherché c'est finalement la négation
de l'ukraine le déni d'ukraine et donc
le fait que l'ukraine soit plis et les
conditions de
négociations proposée par le président
poutine n'ont pas changé depuis 11 jours
c'est à dire c'était conditions de
négociation soumission
et cela nous paraît inacceptable on ait
eu l'occasion au cours de cette
rencontre de réaffirmer notre totale
solidarité avec leucan ce qui me frappe
le plus je crois que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises dans d'autres lieux
c'est d'abord que l'union européenne a
été uni alors que le président poutine
comptait sur nos divisions
elle a été unie elle a été rapide dans
ses décisions elle a été forte dans ses
décisions audacieuses même l'europe
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui n'est plus
la même que celle qui existait il ya dix
jours encore temps le chemin qualitatif
le fait de soutenir l'ukraine n'est y
compris dans le domaine des équipements
militaires le fait qu'ils aient de des
sanctions énormes qui ont été décidées
et qui sont mises en oeuvre que cela se
passe dans une très grande rapidité le
seul fait même qu' on puisse se mettre
d'accord sur la protection temporaire
des réfugiés en quelques heures sur des
sujets où il faut des compromis
généralement très long et très compliqué
où chacun doit faire des efforts et l'a
rapidement ça se met en oeuvre tout ça
aboutit au fait que la violence de la
tacc de l'ukraine par la russie a
entraîné une stimulation très forte de
la part de l'union européenne qui du
coup fait qu' elle n'est plus la même
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait encore des jours
et je suis convaincu que cela se
confortera et se confirmera lors du
sommet qui va se tenir en france jeudi
et vendredi à l'initiative du président
macron voilà l'essentiel de ce que je
voulais dire
ministre est maintenant passe aux
questions et je vais prendre des
questions dans la salle et la première
question ce sera pour patrick thegero de
rtl
genre on passe aux questions donc oui
bonjour oui bonjour messieurs juste pour
vous demander quel est selon vous le
rôle que peut tenir la chine dans la
situation actuelle donc on essaie
relations avec la russie elle laisse
entendre qu'elle pourrait jouer les
intermédiaires qu'en pensez vous
pendant la réunion de jeudi marc santé
moment pour avoir une longue
conversation avec des ministres les
chinois à mon avis il s'agit pas de
médiation
mais c'est évident que la cl
une influence clair sur la russie et on
a discuté de la situation telle qu'elle
est le
ses origines de son évolution
prévisible
j'étais modère la sinne de tuer toute
son influence les faire partie d'une
initiative diplomatique que pour essayer
d'avoir un 16-2 feu immédiat et des
négociations qui se tiennent en bonne et
due forme c'est évident que la syrie
peut jouer un rôle j'étais pas des
médiateurs ce que c'est évident que l
est beaucoup plus proche de la position
de la position de la russie mais
oui on peut jouer un rôle d' influence
parce que là si c'était toujours une
grande puissance mondiale
célia est ce son âme
ça prend limiter
ce point de vue commun avec la chine
sont bien évident donc c'est quelqu'un
qui peut jouer un rôle très important si
elle ne veut pour pousser par une chose
est sûre diplomatique à la sortie de la
crise
je partage
ce sentiment le président de la
république va s'entretenir avec le
président tchi kan ce demain à priori si
l'agenda est toujours maintenue dans ces
termes pour faire valoir au président
chinois que la chine a aussi des
responsabilités
elle est membre du conseil de sécurité
et à ce titre là des responsabilités sur
l'évolution des situations
conflictuelles dans le monde et
singulièrement du fait d'une relative
proximité qui a été manifestée lors de
l'accord entre le président poutine de
président si c'était peut-être février
dernier elle a des responsabilités
qu'elle peut exercer parce qu'elle peut
faire pression sur la russie est le seul
fait que la chine se soit abstenu dans
le vote au conseil de sécurité
est un signe qu'il n'ya pas
totalement alignement des positions de
l'un et de l'autre ce qui permet une
capacité d'agir et je pense que un grand
pays une grande puissance membres du
conseil de sécurité d'autoriser de son
influence pour éviter la poursuite de du
pire
maintenant nous allons prendre une
question d'un journaliste connecter sur
zoom et ses fins chaque brique de t rex
bonjour je vous remercie j'ai une
question pour monsieur le drian
économie est-ce que vous m'entendez
sinon je suis en france elle est décédée
ouais ok
on m'a dit que je suis en anglais pour
l'époque désolé pour la coop hausse
continue pourquoi c'est toujours pas
signé et accroît sa soeur ses
partenariats et on est capable de passer
plusieurs mois sans en accords signés
soit de la part de la commission
européenne pour les états membres par
chaque état membre est-ce que cet accord
finalement ça sert à pas grand chose non
vu qu'on a déjà ses relations entre
l'union africaine l'union européenne
en entend souvent on entend souvent que
le partenariat avec les pays acp cp et
ça aide la commission ne retient à
tisser les liens avec des pays dans les
organisations internationales
mais ça n'a pas permis par exemple de
mettre une française à la tête de l'aef
à eau et donc on se demande concrètement
à quoi ça sert aujourd'hui l'accord post
pour cotonou merci il est essentiel il a
fait l'objet de discussions longues
qui ont permis d'aboutir à un dispositif
qui n'est pas uniquement un dispostif
africains vous l'avez rappelé vous même
et j'espère que nous pourrons aboutir à
une signature sous présidence française
et maintenant je donne la question 1
juliette khabar de la fp
bonjour je voulais savoir quelles
évolutions on pouvait attendre du côté
donc 2
l'ouverture de couloirs humanitaires
safra
apparemment l'objet la deux d ce sera le
point central des nouveaux pourparlers
russo ukrainien qui vont se tenir dans
les heures qui viennent
le président maquereau a dénoncé une
position cynique de la russie enfin
comment vous voyez la situation évolue
et j'ai eu l'occasion de dire hier
que
dans l'évolution de la situation
militaire
on allait vers une période de très
difficile qui était la période des
sièges
siège de karkhiv
siège de mario poehl qui sont engagés
mais qui n'ont pas abouti en raison de
la forte résistance qui est exercée par
les militaires et la population civile
ukrainienne siège de ma d'odessa siège
de main de kiev
or
nous avons sur les sièges initié par
les forces armées russes
une sinistre expertise
dans la dernière manifestation récente
était celle d'alec
avec sans arrêt le même scénario c'est
ce que j'ai dit renoncer avant les
événements d'aujourd'hui
bombardements
proposition de corridors sanitaire
humanitaire
dénonciation de la rupture du corridor
par l'adversaire
alors qu'il ya une provocation qui est
fait par celui qui lui-même délimite le
corridor
tentative de
négociation et pour parler pour mieux
condamner l'adversaire qui sort de ces
négociations parce qu on le provoque à
sortir rebond barre de man et on
recommence
regardez l'histoire d'alep c'est comme
cela regardez l'histoire de grozny en
tchétchénie c'est comme cela est
malheureusement nous sommes un nouveau
rendez vous il ne faut pas tomber dans
les pièges
il ya un principe c'est l'accès libre
humanitaire partout
et cet accès libre humanitaire partout
il existe dans aussi dans le droit
humanitaire international
c'est ce principe là qui doit être
respectée et c'est ce principe qui
aujourd'hui bafoués donc je ne fais pas
de ce concept du corridor humanitaire
un concept que je partage nous demande
même si dans les écoles de guerre russe
il n'ya pas des cours pour expliquer
bombardements corridor négociations
rupture on recommence c'est assez
dramatique mais ces malheureuses ça fait
malheureusement froid dans le dos
oui en effet je crains fort quand va
vers et si les
civilisations
et le grain
ce cyclone autre conférence de presse
nous vous remercions
le sionisme monsieur le représentant
merci beaucoup et bonne journée merci
beaucoup